you guys see that video of me wheelian
right there were you doing a wheelie too
filming him doing I'm sure I'm sure yeah
he films me I filmed him you know
I remember the first time he started to
do wheelies it was really sketchy yeah
he had he's got a lot of send in him to
be honest look at that yeah that's a
that's a 700 pound bike you know yeah so
dude what you're supposed to do is you
know you clutch it up you go slow as
possible first gear you could you know
other bikes are different with the
Harley you know it's a lot of torques I
hadn't like you get in first gear you
throw it up and then once you get so far
back I mean you're either falling or
you're gonna touch the back brake and
that'll bring you forward uh you give a
little throttle and then a little break
and then you start balancing it out and
dude he got it faster than probably
anybody I've ever ridden with now I was
literally like obsessed with it like I I
literally like didn't I didn't care
about anything in life but learning how
literally every day out there I would
just be riding around on my bike for
hours until I got it down just always on
a wheelie